Charles darwin,
the miles managed son of a physician
was once described as the most dangerous
man in England.
In fact,
many people would consider them to be
the agents of the devil himself come to
sow seeds of corruption.
Among the faithful is ideas struck
like a storm at the very foundation of
society turning conventional
religious thought on its hat.
Yes.
Just a few years earlier,
he had his sights set on becoming a
priest and devoting his life to God.
In this week's biographics we investigate
the life and the ideas of Charles
Darwin.
Charles Robert Darwin
was born in Shrewsbury,
England on February the 12th 1809 his
father Robert was a doctor and his mother
Susanna.
It was the daughter of the
famous potteries owner,
Josiah Wedgwood jars.
His grandfather was Erasmus Darwin,
well known in his time as a
scientist with unusual ideas.
He wrote on a range of subjects
including travel by air.
We're exploring by
submarine and evolution.
Despite his learned father and
eminence grandfather Charles,
his early years were not outstanding.
He attended Shrewsbury School were the
main lessons where in the classics such
as Latin,
his school masters and his
father considered them to
be a boy of very ordinary
intelligence despite his
apparent lack of promise.
Charles showed a great
interest in learning boss
rather than studying Greek and
in like most of the students of the time,
he was taken with the English poetry
of William Wordsworth and Lord Byron.
When Charles was a teenager,
science began to captivate them so
much so in fact that he had his brother
Erasmus build a chemistry lab in a
garden shed in 1825 Charles attended
Edinburgh medical school in Scotland,
but he was not a good medical students.
He found the lectures dull.
Ma'Ams had to leave the operating theater
because he could not stand the horrors
of surgery.
One thing he did enjoy though
was the study of taxidermy,
which he learns from a format
African slave named John Edmondson.
During his second year in Scotland,
Darwin joins the Plinian Society,
a club for naturalists.
He was taken with that
intellectual debates,
which exposed him to ideas
of how man was created,
not buying guns,
but by gradual changes in form.
Over time,
these ideas had been espoused by Charles,
his own grandfather,
Erasmus,
Darwin,
while of the university,
Darwin Matters.
Ecologist named Robert Grants,
and the two became close friends.
Grant has been credited with being the
first person to interest Darwin in the
theory of evolution.
At this time,
Charles began collecting fossils
since learning more about animal life,
so the great disappointment of his father
Charles quit medical school in 1827 he
joined his uncle Josiah Wedgwood,
the second for a trip to Paris as see
vacations his father still fretting over
his son dropping out of medical school,
made plans for Charles to study
for the clergy enrolling him.
It's Christ's College
Cambridge University.
Despite the evolutionary ideas that had
been filling his mind's during his time
at Edinburgh,
Charles still held to
a belief in creation.
Later he rose.
I did not then in the least doubt,
these strict and literal truth
of every word in the Bible.
During the summer before
his studies began,
Charles fell in love with a girl by the
name of Fanny Oh in the sister of one of
his friends.
They spend long hours talking,
riding horses and playing cards.
Darwin's theological studies at Cambridge
began towards the end of 1827 but
rather than getting immersed in the Bible,
he developed a fondness
for collecting beetles.
He attended lectures on botany given
bunny the reverend John Stevens Henslow.
Darwin saw this as a possible career
path and he pursued his studies with
enthusiasm.
By ACR 29 it became clear that Darwin
had no interest in joining the clergy.
He spent that spring break with the
Reverend Frederick hope and noted
entomologist.
Here's obsession with
the study of Beatle Song,
no time for his budding
romance with fanny,
and they broke up that following spring.
Despite his general lack of
interest in his clerical studies,
Darwin past his finals exam in January,
1831 basing 10 fitness
class finished with school.
He was all set to become a countryside
clergy or the edge one with a deep
scientific interest,
but reverend Hansley who had become
something of a mentor to Charles suggested
that he should see some of the world's
before he settled down to his posting to
oh in decided to take a trip to the
Canary Islands off the coast of Spain.
He plans to go with his
friend's Momma do Ramsey.
They intended to study the
geological formations on the islands,
but before they could set sail,
Ramsey died.
Suddenly Darwin was stricken with grief
and could not travel to the islands.
A few weeks later he received a letter
from reverend Henslow informing him that
there was an opening on a
ship that may interest him.
The HMS Beagle,
which was bound for South America.
The bagel was being repaired as one of
several ships scheduled to map South
America.
Robert Fitzroy,
the captain of the Beagle,
recognize that the long
voyage would require for a
variety of men to be on board
for companionship.
He was keen to have a scholar gentlemen
who could help describe the areas that
were being charted as well as to
relieve the TDM between ports of call.
When the opening presented itself,
Darwin was keen to fill the spot.
However,
his father Roberts refused to give his
adult son permission to embark on a
voyage.
Robert's continued to
believe that Charles,
his interest in science was
merely a passing fad and
that the young man remained
adrift.
It was left to Charles,
his uncle Joe Cya to step in
and to persuade his brother
to give permission for
his son to join the expedition.
Charles then hastened to London's and
meet with caps in Fitzroy in the hope of
that the offer was still available.
He was in luck with plans
for a September departure,
gradually moved back the ship.
Finally set sail on Tuesday,
December the 27th 1831 Darwin
found himself in a small
cabin that was nine feet
by 11 feet long and only five feet high.
Part of his cabin was taken over by one
of the masts rising through it from the
start.
He was seasick.
A condition that remained
over the next five years.
On January the 16th 1830 do the big or
stopped at Cape Verde off the western
coast of Africa,
her Darwin founder band of fossil shells,
45 feet above sea level.
How he wondered the fossils rise so high.
After 23 days,
the crew was set out for Brazil arriving
in the port city of Salvador at the end
of February,
1832 are up to spring.
The big old traveled along the Brazilian
coast stopping in many ports at each
stop.
Darwin took long hikes.
Collecting many specimens he could likes
is a huge number of specimens which he
carefully catalogs and protected
on board Fitzroy and the crew.
They consider this work worthless and
is growing collection a load of junk,
but to trials,
they were precious scientific discoveries.
Every few months.
He arranged for a shipments to be sent
back to reverend Henslow in Cambridge for
safekeeping from Brazil,
the Beagle at sales to Patagonia,
a large region of South
America that is now Argentina.
They're Darwin collected fossils,
bits of bone and feathers that
he had never before encountered.
He struggles to accurately record
their features in the hopes that more
experienced naturalists could later
help to identify them from Patagonia.
The Beagle went further
to Tierra del Fuego.
It was here that Darwin encountered native
people who still dwells in the jungle
and were considered to be
at savages by the Europeans.
By march of 1833 the crew of the Beagle
began mapping the Falkland Islands,
which the British had claimed from
Argentina actress months earlier,
fascinated by the burdens animal
fossils found that Darwin spent his time
comparing the specimens with everything
he had collected to date the work that
Darwin was immersed in.
It was becoming so exhaustive that he
recognized the need to take on a servant.
He wrote home to his father asking
for the money to hire someone.
When permission came back,
he asked the ships odd job,
man,
sims coverings,
and to take on the role.
Meanwhile,
the letters that Charles had been sending
back to reverend tens low were being
read aloud to the Philosophical
Society of Cambridge.
This owns Darwin and early reputation as
an excellent naturalist and observer on
Darwin's 25th birthday.
Captain Fitzroy names the highest
mountain in the Tierra del Fuego region
mounts.
Darwin in Charles is on that by 1834 the
ship had sailed round Cape Horn at the
southern tip of South America and
crossed from the Atlantic to the Pacific
Ocean.
During the summer,
Darwin became quite ill.
He was deemed too sick to continue the
voyage and spent four frustrating months
in Tierra del Fuego.
Recovering.
Historians believe that
he had chagas disease,
which is a form of sniffing sickness.
Though in returns of the
Beagle in November of 1834
the ship rounded Cape Horn
and sales up self,
America's west coast.
On February the 20th 1835 a great
earthquake shook the region and during the
boards of Concepcion in Chile,
Darwin saw the appalling damage.
He also noted that the rocks around the
harbor had been lifted almost a meter by
the earth's movements,
shellfish and seaweeds,
which were normally near the water.
We're now high and dry,
so could such catastrophic
changes in the surroundings.
The linked to changes in parts
and animals is what he wondered.
The Beagle now left South America and set
sail across the Pacific Ocean almost a
thousand kilometers from the mainland.
It angered does a group of about 13
small rocky islands on the equator.
These were of course
the Galapagos Islands.
Darwin was immediately struck by
the strange nature of the birds,
reptiles and others that he found that
they seemed unique to these islands.
Yet they had many similarities to
species founds on these South American
mainland's stranger still each
island had its own kind of animal.
One example was the giant tortoises
winning more than 200 kilograms,
which the ship's crew
right around like horses.
The local people could tell which island
did tortoise came from by the shape of
its shell.
Darwin was especially intrigued
by one group of birds,
the finches,
they were mostly small and drab,
Brown in color,
but each species had a slightly different
size and shape of beak allowing it to
tackle a certain kind of food.
Darwin noted in his notebook,
one made really fancy that
from an original paucity of
birds in the archipelago,
one species had been taken and
modified for different ends.
The idea of evolution,
but it was beginning to take root.
The bagel sailed on across the Pacific
to Tahiti where Darwin fell in love with
the misty peaks,
tropical plants,
colorful animals,
and these simple natural
lifestyle of the local people.
The journey continued on towards
New Zealand and then Australia.
He was shocked at the terrible living
conditions of the local people and the own
lands.
They were ruled over and made
slaves by European settlers.
This seemed to support his observations
from the animal world that the stronger
always took over from the week.
Okay.
The Beagle returned to Fallon,
the thing balloons on the 2nd of October,
1836.
They had been away for five years.
Darwin's spend the next
few years organizing and
cataloging his vast collection
of plants,
animals,
rocks,
and fossils.
By the summer of 1838,
Darwin felt bold enough to share
his radical ideas with this father.
We took them in his straight
for the last several months.
Charles had struck up a close
relationship with his cousin,
Nema Wedgewood.
However,
when he brought up the
subject of marrying and uh,
his father warned that she
came from a very strict family,
Amma would never consider Darwin's
theories as anything but heresy deeply in
love.
Though Darwin ignored his father's
advice to curtail the romance.
He mentioned some of his notions
regarding religion in nature to Emma.
It was surprisingly understanding Darwin
juggled numerous tasks from writing
books to studying more fossils to watching
apes and hangs at the London Zoo as
he works.
He also continued his
relationship with Emma.
You proposed to her on November the 11th,
1838.
The proposal was well received
by both sides of family.
Arrangements were made for
Darwin to receive a handsome
annual sum of money from
his father.
This would allow the couple to live while
Darwin continued retaining Covington
services.
Since research on his theory of
evolution was still incomplete,
jaws and Emma were married
on January the 29th,
1839 the couple of settles
into her home in London,
which was already filled
with scientific material.
Shortly thereafter,
Covington left Darwin's employment
to make his own fortune.
He was replaced by a man
named Joseph Pass Layer.
During the spring of 1839
Darwin carried out research.
I'm crossbreeding.
He asked various experts,
including farmers questions about
how they crossbred their animals.
He filled page off the page
with his correspondences in May.
The multivolume collection he wrote
with Captain Fitzroy narrative of the
surveying voyages of the HMS Beagle
was finally released to the public.
This celebration of the beagles voyage,
it became a best seller.
Charles was now a respected scientist
and author and as a member of the royal
society
during the 1814 and 1850 stolen,
continued his research and writing.
In 1842 he wrote a geology book entitled
the structure and distribution of coral
reefs with two more geology books
following in the next few years.
As time went on,
his health began to fail.
He could only do a few
hours of work each day.
His illness,
it was never identifies,
but it could have been the after
effects of his tropical sickness.
While on his five year voyage.
Despite his illness,
he continued his research.
And so the idea of evolution,
he was becoming more and more convinced
that species we're not fixed and
immutable.
He had written a short version of his
ideas in 1842 but decided to collect every
scrap of information he could and write
a lengthy book with masses of evidence
for his theory.
For many years,
Darwin was reluctance to publish his
ideas on evolution by natural selection.
It's meant that animals and
plants evolved naturally.
He now believed that God
have not created them.
However,
most people at the time,
including many scientists,
still believed in the truth of the Bible.
He knew that speaking out against the
accepted teachings of the Bible was set
into a fence and cause a storm of protest.
Darwin may have never finished
his work on evolution,
but for a letter which arrived
at his home in Kent in June,
1885 from Malaysia,
it was from another English naturalist,
Alfred Wallace.
Wallace knew that Darwin
was interested in evolution.
So with his letter he sent
his summary of the theory.
Darwin was amazed.
All of the work he had so patiently
done over the last 20 years was neatly
described by Wallace as a scientific
meeting at the nae and society in London.
The works of both Wallace and Darwin
were read outs in July of 1858 after that
one,
it's agreed the Darwin who had gathered
far more evidence to support their joint
theory should carry on with the idea while
he stood aside to Olin did say weekly
finishing his great book.
It was published on the 24th of November,
1859 and it was called
the origin of species.
The publisher of Darwin's book,
John Mary Reddit's before printing it
and realized a great outcry would follow.
As a result,
he only printed 1,250 copies.
These sold out almost at once and a
second edition was quickly produced.
They've all,
they were indeed outraged.
Darwin one's denying the truth that was
in the Bible scientists and lined up to
have their say with
many criticizing Darwin.
One clergymen cools,
the quiet,
mild mannered Darwin,
the most dangerous man in England,
but others quickly recognized the good
signs in Darwin as ideas and to the vast
amount of evidence which supported them.
The biologist Thomas Huxley spoke for
him in England while professor of botany
at Harvard University,
a sick gray it.
It's great supporter in North America.
Darwin himself stayed in camps and
took little part in the arguments.
So now the question arises,
well,
what did Darwin actually
postulate in his famous book?
Well,
the origin of species by means of
natural selection or the preservation of
favored races in the struggle for
life is a long but very readable book.
It begins by looking at
variation under domestication,
including pigeons,
horses,
and garden flowers.
Then it covers variation in nature and
the problems of identifying a species.
It shows how the offspring of parents
are all similar but slightly different.
These slight differences might give an
individual a better chance of succeeding
and staying alive.
Laser chapters deal with animal instincts,
fossils,
and the geographical and manner of
animals and plants from mice to elephants.
Yet.
He never explains the
origin of any one species.
As I mentioned,
the origin of species,
sharks and angered many people including
Darwin own family to accept the theory
of evolution meant accepting that the
accounts in the Bible of creation of
animal and plant species
could not be true.
Many scientists,
they simply struggles to
believe in both gradually.
However,
the theory of evolution by
natural selection gained
grounds and most scientists
came to believe that
Darwin was right Darwin,
he did not retire after the
origin of species was published.
He kept up his studies and researchers
and carried on with his experiments and
nature observations.
In 1871 he published descent of man
then selection in relation to sex.
In this work,
he concluded that humans are not
the result of special creation,
but that they have evolved
along with other animals.
Their ancestors could indeed be
traced back far into prehistory.
In the 1870s Darwin's health improved
and in 1877 he was awarded a special
degree by Cambridge University.
He continued to write books
about insect eating plants,
how plants grow and move,
and how they encourage decay and enrich
the soil with Descente huge success as
well.
Darwin divided his time
between revising the two works.
In April of 1874 he completed
work on descents second edition.
This was the last time he wrote about
evolution between projects and illnesses.
Darwin continued to refine his work
a decade after its first publication.
The fifth edition of origin was released.
The sixth edition published in 1871 use
the word evolution for the first time
after a mild heart attack in December of
1881 Charles Darwin died several months
later,
peacefully at down house.
His home of Nettie 50 years.
He was 73 years old.
By this time,
the storm of protests over the origin
of species had died away and Darwin had
become a national figure and one of the
best known scientific names of all time.
It was laid to rest at Westminster Abbey
London next to the Great Isaac Newton.
The funeral was attended
by dozens of politicians,
inventors,
explorers,
scientists,
and artists along with members of the
scientific communities of many countries.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.